so what exactly do you do all
day I chase down
[Music]
stories what do you love most about your
job I'd say the unpredictability of
it never knowing what's coming
next
Jack you did not come to Tokyo in
pursuit of one man
there are other
stories other crimes to be
exposed that is your
job if you saw anything that can help me
now's my chance I saw a
[Music]
tattoo you know I'm want something Jas
it tell no
[Music]
one
watch yourself don't be stupid don't be
stupid I have to remember
[Music]
that on sure
who knows what he'll do if to thinks we
have this information maybe you should
lay
low today a man told me he'd kill me if
I don't stop writing I think you got to
keep going be
careful other people are relying on you
now you are the way this
[Music]
ends
fore
[Music]
foree